-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-So now I thought I'd share some
of my favorite,
#MyWeirdSecret tweets
from you guys.
here we go, this first one's
from @ratchel78.
She says, "When I'm in the
shower and a sad song comes on
I pretend I'm in a movie
and I'm breaking up
with someone in the rain."
-Aw.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not you, shampoo, it's me.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @lindsspace
She says, "When getting banana
I can't tear them apart.
It's like they're family.
If I see a banana alone,
I put it next to a new bunch."
-Aw.
[ Laughter ]
-That's very nice.
That's thoughtful.
-Oh, that's sweet.
-You never know.
-That's just sweet.
-That's very nice.
This one's from @simontobey.
He says, "Whenever I leave a
store and don't buy anything
I walk out extra slowly so tha
no one thinks I stole anything."
[ Laughter ]
-Hey.
-That happens to me all the time
like when I leave Barnes & Noble
they have those giant
security wall things.
And I'm just leaving.
and I'm like [Gasps] Ooh, did I?
I didn't steal anything.
Of course I did, but.
[ Laughter ]
Just a couple Nooks.
This one's from @Marie-Cucinella
oh, Cunicella, I apologize
She says, "Sometimes when I'
cooking, I talk out loud t
a fake camera and pretend that
I have my own cooking show."
[ Laughter ]
We're just gonna let this simmer
right here and come over here,
we're gonna make
a little, my secret is a littl
lemon in there.
[ Laughter ]
I do that, too.
Oh, this is great. This one'
from @Penswild87.
She says, "Sometimes I randoml
go out and buy balloons
to cheer myself up."
-Aw.
-I do that with beer, so don't
worry about it it's fine.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @EBelindaKeaton.
She says, "I sometimes put son
lyrics in Ziploc bags
so I can sing them properly in
the shower."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-That's a life hack right there.
That's fantastic.
I'm gonna steal that.
-Yeah, then you can also pretend
like you're being broken up with
in a movie.
-No, that's true.
-You know?
-This one's from @jenball10.
She says, "Sometimes when I'
watching "Family Feud,"
I like to see if I can look up
the families on Facebook.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, why not?
They're real families.
-Yeah, come on,
they're real families.
-Survey says! That's creepy.
Survey says, that's creepy
[ Laughter ]
I would like that.
See some family photos of them
-Yeah.
-Uh, this one's from
@asencio-ryan.
He says, "When I don't lik
someone, I make an avatar
of them on the Sims and make
them live a hard life."
[ Laughter ]
You have high cholesterol. I'd
like to order three more pizzas.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @richandcorey.
He says, "I had a dead battery
collection when I was little
I would spread them out on m
bed and just stare at them."
[ Laughter ]
That's sad. That is just sad
-That is sad.
-This last one here's from
@Stephy-steph25.
She says, "If I miss the cla
part of the "Friends"
theme song, I have to watc
another episode
so I can do the clap and get i
out of my system."
[ Laughter ]
I got you there.
There you have it. Those are
Tonight Show Hashtags.
To check out more of our
favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-I thought I'd share some of m
favorite,
#MyDumbInjury tweets
from you guys, here we go.
This first one's from @scarr257.
[ Laughter ]
-Scar?
-Scar, yeah.
-Well, first of all his name's
"Scar."
-I know, that's what I'm saying.
-he does have a lot of injuries.
He says, "I dislocated my knee
playing charades
and everyone thought it was part
of the charade."
[ Laughter ]
It's like.
-Pain!
-Pain, pain! Joint paint.
-Injury.
Arthritis.
[ Laughter ]
-Limping. Ah, oh, ER. ER?
This is from @Mander9696.
He says, "My leg accidentall
fell though the trampoline
springs and I was stuck.
My pug saw it happen and began
humping my leg."
[ Laughter ]
"Go get help, boy!
Get out of here!"
-At least somebody won.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @idgeddes7.
He says, "Once at a dance I wa
doing the worm and split my chin
open on the dance floor.
Then I just danced off cryin
like nothing happened."
[ Laughter ]
-Leaving a trail of blood.
-This one's from @JordanPhilly
He says, "My cousin jumped off
the kitchen counter and landed
on a Christmas cookie cutter
Now she's got a scar in th
shape of Santa Claus."
[ Laughter ]
-Dumb or the best?
-Kind of cool, actually that's
pretty cool.
-If you've gotta have a scar
-Yeah everyone likes
Santa Claus.
-Ask @scarr257.
-I know.
This one's from @GregMaxwell85
He says, "I shocked myself
plugging in an old TV cord
After the third shock,
I sat down
and forgot what I was doing.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Imitates electric shock ]
[ Imitates electric shock
[ Imitates electric shock,
garbles ]
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from
@KristenRose124. She says --
-Hey, Jimmy.
-Hey. Whoa. Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi.
-Steve.
-Judd Apatow. Judd Apatow. What?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, buddy.
Nice to see you.
What are you doing here?
-You know, I heard about you
hand and I was just worrie
about you and just wanted to
check up on you.
-That's very, very nice.
That's very very cool of you
-I also thought this was a
incredible
marketing opportunity.
[ Laughter ]
-Excuse me?
-Well, I got a movie coming out,
"Trainwreck,"
you guys gonna go?
[ Cheers and applause ]
And it opens tomorrow nigh
but I think if you go tonigh
Manohla Dargis loved it.
-Okay good.
-Yeah, and I thought, you're
kind of a human train wreck.
Right?
-Not really. But yeah, I guess
-And this is a lot of ad space
This is a lot of ad space.
So I thought, because it looke
so weird and white,
we'd put that right there.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay?
-Yeah.
-And now sit down.
-Okay.
-And then,
for the rest of the show i
looks better
and it promotes the movie.
Look.
Put that out of the way.
[ Laughter ]
-That's the "Tonight Show" logo.
-And then when you interview
people just scratch your chi
a little bit.
-Like that?
-Yeah.
-But I don't do that.
-And then fix the eyebrows every
once in awhile during the show
-Fix my eyebrows?
That covers my whole face.
-Wait hold on a second.
-[ Laughs ]
-Anyway, I'm so glad you fee
better. I hope it sticks.
-I didn't say I didn't fee
better. thank you. Bye, Judd
Judd Apatow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He said I felt better.
He didn't even let me answer t
see if I did feel better.
-[ Laughs ]
There you go.
Perfect.
Make sure it's straight.
-[ Laughs ]
Uh, this one's from
@KristenRose124.
-What's she say?
-She says, "I punched the window
out of a car to save a dog stuck
inside and broke my hand.
The dog was actually a wig and I
had to pay $750."
[ Laughter ]
-You just -- yeah.
That's --
-At least the wig didn't start
humping her.
-That's true.
-That would've been weird.
-Or did it?
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, this last one
has a picture, you guys.
It's from @JordanRayHalsey
He says, "I fell down the stairs
while taken a selfie.
Broke my toe and got this
picture."
There you are
and there you have it.
Those are
Tonight Show Hashtags.
To check out more of our
favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-Now I'm gonna share
some of my favorite
#NewWeedLaws tweets
from you guys.
This first one's from
@TeruTeruJiru.
She says, "All menus should be
like the one at Denny's;
Large pictures of food so yo
can just point at what you wan
without having to talk."
It's like, uh.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-[ Grunts ]
-[ Laughs ] You grunted?
[ Laughter ]
-Dude. Dude.
-Dude?
-Dude. Du-ude.
-Oh, dude.
-Du-ude.
[ Laughter ]
-Dude?
Dude or dude?
-Dude.
-Dude or dude?
Oh, okay I'll go with the dude
Yeah you're right.
[ Grunting ]
-Yoinks.
-This one's from @NeverleftOz.
-Uh-oh.
-She says,
"All public parks will hav
"Contemplating benches,"
where you can just sit
and really think about stuff."
[ Laughter applause ]
I think that's what benches are.
-Yeah I think -- yeah.
-You can do that now at a bench.
-Yeah.
Dude.
-Dude, have a seat.
This one's from @Bigten119
He says, "All video games must
have a "Stoned"
difficulty level."
Oh, well that's --
[ Applause ]
Ah, forget it, man,
I don't know.
-Turns into a kaleidoscope
-This one's from @yrocdrumz.
He says, "Rap songs can't be
allowed to have
police sirens in them anymore.
Yeah I know
what you're talking about.
-Yeah.
[ Both imitating police sirens ]
[ As police ] Pull over!
-What happened?
-What, I'm discussing this s
bust it.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, well, this one's from
@ShnitzGabai.
-Shnitz? Shnitz? Not -- with a
"N" or without an "N"?
-Shnitz. Of course.
-Okay Shnitz.
-ShnitzGabai.
N-Not "goodbye."
G-A-B-A-I.
-Gabai?
-Gab-eye?
-Gu-bye.
-G'bye.
-Shnitz, goodbye,
-Hey Shnitz, bye.
-Shnitz, goodbye.
-Imodium A-D.
-That's not, yeah like wha
Heidi Klum says
of the reality show,
if you lose.
She goes, "Shnitz, goodbye."
And that's it.
But that's different.
This is different.
-Okay.
-I thought it was like an
anti-diarrhea medicine.
-Shnitz?
[ Laughter ]
Dude, I'll have the
Look at my new T-shirt, dude
-I want the chicken
-Dude.
-Duh.
Uh, Shnitz says, "In all drive
licenses, the description
of eye color will be permanently
changed to red."
[ Laughter ]
Everyone has red eyes.
He's 6 foot tall,
he had red eyes.
Half closed.
[ Laughter ]
This last one is from
@KingBayhive -- err, Beyhive
He says, "There should be
separate line at fast food
for the "I just smoked, so thi
might take awhile" customers."
There you go. Those are Tonigh
Show Hastags.
To check out more of our
favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags